well the pitcher for uh the washington
nationals paolo espino the panamanian
right-hander one of the things that
we're seeing this year is because of all
the injuries almost everyone is getting
a chance 1500 innings pitched over 13
minor league seasons 34 years old
mcneil hits one on the ground through
the hole into right field of base hit
and that's how this game begins mcneil
who went over 12 in the series against
the phillies gets a base hit on the
second pitch he sees from paulo espino
so the mints have a lead off base runner
against espino and now francisco lindor
this is basically a bullpen game for the
nats it was supposed to be eric fetty's
start
and he drove this one to right field and
back goes soda to pick it off for the
out
bart hit ball off the bat of lindor but
he's retired for the first out of the
game now the set of the pitch swinging
the ground ball right side big hop
harrison to second for one turn her back
to first double play and the inning is
over that'll go four six three to retire
the side jared eichoff 30 years of age
as a philly five career starts against
the nets one and one with a respectable
2-7-0 well four-seam slider guy what a
pair of indiana guys here at schwarber
and jared ikov 6-4 246 pounds and the
pitch swung on belted deep to right way
up down the line and this one in the
upper deck and god goodbye
[Music]
another tape measure home run for kyle
schwarber that one looked like he went
over the foul pole ferrari angle tough
to say if it would have been fair
but sam holbrook the crew chief with the
immediate signal
that one about halfway up the third deck
in right field estimated distance 439
feet bang zoom goes schwarber he has
done it again
with a game lead-off home run here in
the first inning trey turner swings
drives one a deep left center way back
back to back home runs on consecutive
pitches that one lands in and out of
section 101 over the visitors bullpen
and drops down into the pad
zoom goes turner with his 13th home run
of the year and rbi number 37. schwaber
is 23rd
turner is 13th it's the nationals two in
the mets nothing he is feeling good
first pitch to him swung on driven to
the air to right center field deep polar
back it's over his
heading for second the right fielder
mckinney over to back up
and get it in and soto's turning and
stopping it second with a double
josh bell and he gets a curveball hits
it on the ground it's knocked down by
alonso and he makes the play to icoff
and finally icoff has it out that ball
looked like it might be ticketed to go
down the line gomez hitting 254 right
and better icob deals horn hit liner to
short caught on the fly by lindor and
that retires the sign that's another
well-struck ball gerardo is up for three
career against jared ikhoff
partner turns on one
right field corner
c
you
later right
down the line and now gerardo joins the
home run and rbi crew well cue it baby
shark let's go
379 feet the estimated distance
hits the pole just above the second deck
it's the nationals three and the mets
nothing three solo home runs
breaking ball head out to center field
shallow in comes para gonna drop for a
base hit
pulling in at second is smith so alonso
with a bloop single and the mets have
two men on so tough break here for
espino you have the ground ball into the
shift with the overturned replay for an
infield hit then a blue pit and now the
mets have mckinney at the plate the
right fielder with the tying run at the
plate checks the runner at second to 3-2
swinging a fly ball down the left-field
side
schwarber chasing over near the line and
fairground has room and he makes the
catch
mckinney is retired for the second out
here's kevin pilar struck out his first
time up smith at second and alonso at
first a 1-1 to him is poked in the air
on the infield he got fooled on a slider
harrison the second baseman is under it
waiting near the bag and he makes the
catch
and espino works out of his first jam
stranding a pair of runners at the top
of the fourth gerardo para is two out of
three at home by the way as annette
and he goes deep to right center again
heading for the scoreboard and it's off
the out of town scoreboard
at nationals park he's now three for
four
with two doubles and a home run 1-0
it's this one in the air shallow toward
left lendor backs up into the outfield
backpedaling still pulled off by dominic
smith who came in and made a two-handed
catch to retire the sides spino flies
out schwarber hit a long home run into
the upper deck in right field leading
off the bottom of the first inning
schwarber launches another one to write
c u
later
two tonight four for the nets and he's
up to 24.
another
multi-home run game for kyle schwarber
his fifth of the year the 13th of his
career
409 feet over the big wall in right
center field
what we're seeing is amazing
and unbelievable
it's the nationals for the mets nothing
there's not been much that jared eichoff
has done in the way of fooling any of
these national hitters but here he is
here's the pitch to gomes and a crack to
right center toward the gap no one's
there this is going to
be down split the outfielders and roll
to the fence alarm picks it up on the
track gomes is in sliding at second with
a double
so the nationals have seven extra base
hits and no singles in this game
and john gomes with his first hit of the
night his sixth double of the year
my drive left field
goes around third the throw by dominic
smith on a bounce is cut off
and there is a vibe in this ballpark as
the nets lead five to nothing on their
first single of the night after seven
straight extra base hits castro picks up
rbi 28 with a bullet to left field
gourmet's at third and then have a
scoring chance here albeit with two outs
and jeff lines went toward the middle
base hit and the mets will get on the
scoreboard guillerme comes him to score
mcneal reaching out and banging one
straight up the middle gets the rbi
single he's now five for five against
wander suero still some work to do
though down by four swear already
runners lead second and first here it
comes swinging a miss he struck him out
with a high cutter and the side retired
so the mets get one five one nets and
looking to put an exclamation point on
this one
and he gets him on a high fastball to
end the inning so reed foley deals with
traffic works around the error by alonso
and sends us to the eight five one
justin miller in the face pete alonso
drives one to deep left field and forget
that that is way out of here peter lonzo
strikes
his 12th home run of the year his 11th
on the road his seventh in this ballpark
and just like that the mets are back in
the game it's five to three this would
be
a big deal if they could do this four is
the biggest deficit they've overcome
this season 2-2 coming
and he drives one to deep right field
and that ball heads toward the wall and
it's out of here billy mckinney follows
alonzo's home run with one of his own
back-to-back home runs for alonso and
mckinney and it's now five to four pitch
number ten the kick and here it comes
strike three called fast ball over the
inside corner
mccann lifting the arms up and out of
the way he crowds the plate and that's
the place for your effective you can get
in on him and hand did just that and now
zim's going to get a chance to hit here
with first base open they would not walk
him with schwarber on deck castro sets
here's the pitch to zam swinging a long
drive deep-seated going going
good goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and a one-run lead is now a four-run
lead
they just keep on cheering
and here comes him
ball crank to left
oh my
para reaches up
and grabs it with a fin
and this game is over